this guy this ukrainian guy their their
leader this guy is badass have you seen
like him just wearing like green
t-shirts giving press conferences yeah
he he's amazing this guy's amazing this
guy is uh
i don't know much about him i don't know
what's going on i don't know what's like
kind of media portrayal versus whatever
else but the guy does come across like a
goddamn hero
[Music]
all right let me tell you a quick story
i don't know if you're going to like
this topic so i want to get it out of
the way if you like it we could spend
the whole time on it but i'm not sure if
if you're going to be into this
so
yeah yeah so it's about the most popular
thing going on right now the ukraine
russian conflict it's not exactly about
ukraine but it's about russia so
something that i've always been
interested in is the russian oligarchs
so
have you ever studied those folks not
studied but you know okay tell me about
it okay so this starts i'm reading a
thing so you're going to see me look off
this starts on november 3rd 1995 in a
remote
siberian town called sergot
basically what happened in this small
cabin
an auction took place for the right to
lend the cash-strapped russian
government tens of millions of dollars
so basically in 95 the russian
government wasn't doing so hot and they
needed money and so they got these banks
uh to come to this meeting and they said
we need some money we need to borrow
some money and also as collateral we're
going to put up shares of some of the
large state-owned companies because at
this point russia was basically going
from uh being a communist nation to
being a private country and so they
still had some like state-owned oil
companies mineral companies basically
like if you think of exxon mobil they
like the government like owned that and
at this point they were trying to figure
out how do we make this so private
individuals can do this and so
at this meeting uh basically only two
bidders showed up and if more bidders
wanted to come it was kind of a pain and
they asked because conveniently there
were no more flights the airport shut
down and you couldn't even book a flight
to come uh into into this small town
by the way your cameras okay you're
there um
and so basically what happened at this
like small cabin is
one company
made a bid to buy a or to loan money to
the government they loaned it they
loaned something like 500 million
dollars
and
that was like a hundred thousand dollars
above the opening bid so people were
bidding to loan money
and
so this this bank loaned money to the
government and then the government had
to pay back the loan at a certain point
like something like a year later and if
they didn't
the bank then was given the the
collateral so the shares in this company
to auction off and they could keep 30 of
the prop
profits so obviously the government
didn't pay back the money and there's
like a lot of like wondering why they
didn't pay up payback basically the idea
is that the current president was like
obviously this is all like we're all
planning this so we don't pay this back
and give us a little bit whatever
so they don't hate that you're saying
it's collusion basically there was a
a handshake wink-wink agreement
basically of what's gonna happen here
yes and so the government doesn't uh pay
back the loans and so now this bank is
basically now has uh a minority
ownership and like 12 large state-owned
corporations
and
they
basically holler at eight to ten guys
guys who are already relatively
successful and they basically said
do you uh you wanna make a bid on this
company i'm gonna make sure no one else
bids on this company but i'll give it to
you you interested and that's exactly
what happened and why would they do that
why would they hook up these individuals
in that way they did it for three
different reasons the first reason and a
lot of this is just like hearsay the
first reason is
the person who was president at the time
who was it ben what was his name
it was the fat guy who yelled at boris
yeltsin yes he was basically said to
these eight or ten businessmen i'm gonna
hook you up you guys hook me up when i'm
when i'm when i'm in office hook it up
i'm gonna hook you up whatever so that's
one theory the second theory is that
they wanted experienced managers in in
to run these companies and the third
theory basically is even though these
eight to ten oligarchs put bids on these
companies and basically they bought the
equivalent of exxon mobil so we're
talking about like a company that's
worth billions of dollars they paid a
hundred million dollars for this company
and so these managers these oligarchs
these eight to ten folks a lot of them
were mildly successful but they were all
in on the government they were all
friends and friends you know they're all
homies
they basically they did take on risk so
like these companies did have debt and
like they had to go and like collude
with other people and fire the rest of
the managers at the company so it was
basically got almost like a pe thing but
it was like pretty dirty
all right and then i forgot to tell you
this but this is the most important
thing uh i can't believe we didn't talk
about this earlier to be honest with you
because if you're listening to this and
you like what you're hearing right now
and you haven't gone and subscribed to
the my first million podcast wherever
you get your podcast
then that's the thing you've got to do
there's nothing more important than
doing that right now and don't do it
because i said to do it
do it because you want to do it do it
because that's who you are
and the government was like yeah we need
we want like these mercenaries to be in
power because if they make these
companies better our
you know our government's gonna be
better the russia's gonna be better and
so
they basically
profits after after this whole deal
profits to these companies grow by 50x
market caps go up by 100x and so there's
here's an example the reason i got
interested in this is there's this guy
named robin uh abraham what's his name
uh ben how do you say his last name
i think it's abramovich
we're gonna call him roman
so roman even knows what the hell you're
talking about right now is
impressive and he's like he's like a
part of your brain that's like outside
of your body and you're like uh brain
what's that name oh yeah
roman's famous roman owns um we're gonna
call broman he owns chelsea the soccer
team so he's like a famous guy and he
owns like this like you know 200 foot
yacht he's like a big deal and basically
he paid a hundred million dollars him
and his partner boris paid a hundred
million dollars and they've just they
came up a little bit of money and then
they went and hollered at like other
rich people and they said hey loan us
some money let's buy this company they
paid a hundred million dollars for a
company that is now like the eighth or
tenth largest oil company in the world
so imagine paying in the mid 90s imagine
paying a hundred million dollars
for
exxon mobil right
insane and so the these companies
explode now they explode partially
because basically what these owners did
these eight to ten oligarchs what they
did was they purposely tanked the
company so it sucked for a long time and
then they bought out the rest of the
minority shareholders so it's again
cronyism there and second these were
government-run companies so they're [__]
and so these private individuals they
did a pretty good job of making them
better and they became far more
profitable
and this created like eight to ten guys
that were worth like up to 40 billion
dollars so at one point one of them was
worth 83 billion dollars and you know
things have changed but it created so
much wealth between these few folks and
it also like trickled down so here's the
craziest part is that a bunch of the
managers of the company so basically
there was like the pre there was like
the the minister of oil or something
like that as a government official he
becomes he sets up this these one of
these companies he eventually becomes
president of one of the companies and
now is worth 8 billion dollars even
though he was like a a government
official so
i thought it was interesting because i
actually wanted to read a book about
these folks because i'm like oh who's
this like rich guy that owns chelsea
football let me like go and learn from
him
and what i realized is like i pretty
much can't learn from him i mean i could
maybe learn some stuff but like
his process is not like replicable i
can't replicate it because he was like
38 and russia had just fallen and he
basically turned zero dollars into
he's worth now like 20 billion dollars
all through this cronyism but
i thought it was incredibly interested
have you not heard about these folks
i've never heard any of that in my life
um
it's crazy it's like it's like the big
bang for like russian rich oligarchs
it's like there was this one meeting and
it kicked off this series of events
that like you know seems
kind of unfathomable how that would
be allowed to happen or just happen um
but then they also consolidated power
right like didn't putin basically like
take all their money and consolidation
so here's their power
here's the second interesting part of
the story and i actually learned this
from listening to ben's podcast so
basically putin was considered like the
anti-corrupt guy for for a minute like
when he was elected he was like you know
i'm not going to stand for that nonsense
and he made an example of one of the
guys one of the billionaires his last
name starts with the k i'm not going to
try to pronounce it it's a challenge he
um
put this guy in jail for 14 years
and he literally put them and so in
russia for some reason they put you in
these like cages and you could like take
pictures of these folks have you ever
seen that like a like a russian serial
killer picture or anything like
so it's like visible from the outside
you mean yeah it's like the mug shot but
it's like literally a cage that sits on
you and people can come and like take
pictures it's weird and anyway this guy
was worth at the time like 15 billion
dollars and putin arrested him for not
paying taxes things like that and put
him in jail for 14 years and he goes to
the other guys he goes you want that to
happen to you no all right let's play
and so a lot of people think that putin
is the richest man in the world and he
owns one of the most expensive homes in
russia and in the world it's like a
billion dollar two billion dollar house
and people are like oh how'd you do that
it was a lot of people dollar house
yeah ben was telling me all right it's a
billion dollar house wow i didn't even
realize that it's uh
it's it's got like it's got script
yeah it is like the account complex it's
got private beaches it's got like pools
on pools it's got guest houses basically
got a hotel on it it's like a house is
maybe not the right way to think of it
but it is a house it's a private
residence for putin and but basically
like there's no proof of this but a lot
of people because even when the panama
papers released they couldn't find
putin's accounts but basically uh
a lot of people are like well so he made
an example out of this one guy
uh
and he went to the rest and goes you all
want to play let's play and and and now
roman by the way really hoping you'd
attempt a putin accent there kind of
disappointed not gonna lie the story is
good but it's just missing that little
something i think that you are giving it
a shot ben i think you have a little
a little bit of the russian twins and
you're speaking
yes they say me i they tell me i speak
good in russian accent i will try is
this like racist can i do this is this
okay i don't know
it's borderline i don't think it's a
race
this we have the the cancellation
vaccination you're allowed to do a uh a
funny funny accent here and people as
long as it's russian if you're listening
you took that too seriously just swipe
over and delete the podcast and go on
with your life
and to wrap this up basically
the way that these guys all work now is
uh a lot of these oligarchs are
part of like the peace keeping like
they're they're part of they're helping
putin like negotiate peace so like the
inner the way that this shit's
intertwined is just bananas it's crazy
and i was like trying to learn about
these folks and i was like oh well like
there's nothing to learn here i can't i
can't do this like this is just crazy
and these guys are so wealthy and and so
it's trickled down but if you basically
a lot of them when that happened were in
their 30s like 35
uh
38 years old and that's why i got
interested in this because i was i
remember years ago reading about these
folks i'm like how does a 38 year old
become worth 3 billion what the hell how
did a 38 year old become ceo of a
diamond mining company and it was a
stupid question what does the word
oligarch actually mean
uh i think it just means when there's a
small group of people that are in power
um
but basically it's sort of like a cartel
basically yeah not well it's like
what do you say ben
it's just like the
typically the way that it is classically
defined is over here you have a monarchy
which is ruled by a single man over here
you have democracy which is ruled by
everyone oligarchy sits in the middle of
like rule by a few handful right yeah
but when we talk about russian
oligarchies a lot of times people will
say that just means like russian rich
people uh russian wealthy rich people
the way that i'm using it is that
there's literally like nine guys who
were given like these 12 companies and
now amongst those nine guys there was
like dozens more where like roman was
like hey i need a homie i need a cousin
to come and run this thing hook it up
and so there's like it's trickled down
beyond that and so now there's hundreds
of them
quick interruption do me a favor
scroll down and you're going to see a
link to the hustle so if you want to
stay up to date on the tech and business
news you need to know check out the
hustle it's a daily email i used to help
write it i love it so check it out
scroll down below
i'm on a
business insider uh news story about
putin's wealth right now just because i
wanted to see the billion dollar house
so the house 1.35 billion it's a crazy
palace with three helicopter landing pad
landing pads and stuff like that but the
thumbnail was putin doing basically like
a bowflex so he's he's like you know
he's basically saying he's got both uh
cables and he's like clearly about to do
like a peck fly and that was the
thumbnail they chose not one of his
palace or his cars or anything like that
that joe's putin wearing three thousand
two no wearing uh
cashmere sweats that cost fourteen
hundred dollars and then a matching top
which just looks like a hanes t-shirt uh
for his workout outfit total which was 3
200 and then it's just like
every picture is hilarious it's like him
choosing with a champagne it's like only
power photos which is really funny and
keep in mind this is a guy who before
this he was in the kgb so it's like the
cia
of america so this is a government
salary person for the last 30 years
so this is crazy yeah ben how did you
feel so you did the how to take with the
world episodes about putin
and uh and i called you up about this i
was like ben re-release the episodes a
lot of people are curious about putin
right now release the like just
re-upload them as new episodes but you
kind of research this guy a lot what i
mean can we talk about this like russia
ukraine thing for a second so like
what's y'all's reaction to this and i
guess like you know the disclaimers is
we're not experts we're just friends
talking about like yo do you hear what's
going on what do you think about this uh
so ben what did you think cause you've
spent a lot of time reading about this
guy
yeah my reaction um is probably
different from most people's um
i think most people who listen to my
podcast
view it as like an anti-putin podcast
like think it's
pretty hard on him and i think in some
ways it is it calls him out for some of
the bad things he's done including
murdering people and uh
like
maybe doing a
false flag domestic terror attack on uh
the russian people so like it's not a
pro putin podcast having said that i
think a lot of people's reaction has
just been like
putin is hitler he's gonna keep marching
through countries until we stop him like
all he wants is
right more power more territory he's a
megalomaniac who's doing this just
because he's tripping and
um
i think that what they're missing a lot
of the psychology of putin of
um
of this is someone who
was as sam said a part of the kgb right
so he's a part of the soviet empire when
it's a big empire he watches it fall
from grace and then he watches his
country get looted
in the in the mid to late 90s
and kind of says to himself
all right well america was supposed to
come in and make the situation better
i'm never trusting these guys again
right
and so then he's watching ukraine get
pulled closer and closer into
um
the european union and nato orbit and
american orbit and they're basically
saying okay yeah they're aligning with
us but that's their prerogative and
don't worry about it this is not we're
not gonna like invade russia or anything
and he's basically saying
no like that's his red line i will never
trust you guys again
and that doesn't make what he's doing
right but i think it is important to
understand
where he's coming from so the motivation
so that we can make the right decisions
and what do you mean by america
america was supposed to come in and fix
what what do you mean by that exactly so
you're saying
post-world war or something
no so it was essentially um
as
the soviet union is coming down uh i
can't remember the name of it but there
was some uh essentially like committee
um with a bunch of harvard guys who come
into moscow and are like hey we're the
experts this is how you do capitalism
essentially
and initially there's like some optimism
right of okay well america seems pretty
great
the soviet union has not been great and
so we're excited about this capitalism
stuff
and it turns out it goes just they just
wear the sweatshirts never went to
harvard
got him
that's right they were they were pulling
the bend they were wearing the
georgetown lost sweatshirt but they
didn't go to georgetown they uh
and uh so things
um the the russian economy really
crashed during the 90s and so that's
that's what i'm talking about gotcha
okay so he's like i've
you know fooled me once [__] you know
shame shame on whoever the [__] okay so
that was your reaction to this as you
were sort of thinking about that sam
what was your reaction as you kind of
saw this all play out
my reaction let's talk about this from i
mean first of all i was like you know
screw putin not a fan but let's talk
about from a business or like a
management perspective when i saw when
i've seen all this
go through or happen i've been watching
a lot of videos on reddit and admittedly
like that's a usa that's an american
website so i'm trying to figure out like
what the truth is i'm seeing these i'm
seeing two things one i'm seeing videos
of like pows uh russian pows and there's
like
i didn't want to be here they go we
don't want to be here we were tricked we
don't we thought we were going to
practice we didn't know what was going
on and they also say
we thought you guys were going to open
us
welcome us with open arms we thought you
were going to love us what are you what
are you doing like why are you being
angry at us and so um i see and they
also show the tanks and the tanks are
[__] they're like from the 80s and 90s
they're bad like and their weapons suck
and so i'm seeing a i like they're they
just and like and they were a little
chubby and like people don't have like
nice haircuts like they do in the middle
like in america like they just like
undisciplined like it just doesn't seem
like it's like a well-oiled machine
that's what i'm seeing in second these
are the most random observations about
this whole thing it's like
reddit videos of guys being like i
thought this was a practice war that's
what they were like these chubby faces
in 1980s tanks like what
i mean look like when you see that
you're like oh this you're like like i
was afraid of you but like maybe i
shouldn't be like you're out of shape um
and the second thing is this guy this
ukrainian guy their their leader this
guy is badass have you seen like him
just wearing like green t-shirts giving
press conferences yeah he he's amazing
this guy's amazing this guy's uh
i don't know much about him i don't know
what's going on i don't know what's like
kind of
media portrayal versus whatever else but
the guy does come across like a goddamn
hero
when you think of the word a hero what
do you think of it's like you know the
president who says you know not i'm not
just ordering you to war i'm going to
the front lines and by the way this
guy's the finance minister he's here
this guy's you know this is my press
secretary he here hold this gun you
don't know how to do it you have it
backwards doesn't matter stand here and
like
basically sending out a video being like
you know hey putin you know go [__]
yourself or like bring it on basically
like the only thing cooler he could have
done is if he was like putin meet me at
the border you and me unarmed
hand-to-hand combat you win you get my
country i win i get your country that's
the only one level up this guy could
have done as far as being you know the
real life macho man randy savage which
is kind of the way he was coming across
as a when he's like a real hero like
very brave
incredibly and what i'm learning what
i'm trying to you know when i watch the
news i try to be on like this is bad and
i want to help
uh the the thought is like how can i use
this to improve and my takeaway here is
what putin has done they they say like
he's like uh they showed him with uh
giving a press conference and he was on
this huge table and his generals were
like literally 20 feet down on this
table and he was kind of by himself and
that was kind of a represent
representation of him him being a little
distant and whereas this guy was like
literally on the streets toasting coffee
in the morning and
my takeaway is
in order to get someone to do something
you have to make them want to do it you
can't force them to do it because if you
force them to do it it's good it's a
short-lived short-term thing right and
with the ukrainians there was a poll
where 90 of them support this guy and
they are all in the streets they're all
like pouring styrofoam into bottles with
gasoline because that's how you make
napalm and they're using it for molotov
cocktails and they like
it sounds weird but it seems like
they're happy in the sense of like they
have a sense of purpose and they have a
community and they have a mission and
maybe not happy is the right word but
like uh
purpose driven and that's the takeaway
that i have from this is if i'm gonna
convince people to do stuff like running
work at a company or whatever you need
to make them want to do it not force
them to do it
yeah that's uh that's a great point they
definitely have like sort of the the
spirit right now um and the morale in
the rally it's sort of like a rally
going on right now and you know
especially under these circumstances you
know definitely like adversity is
something that pulls people together so
you know it's definitely done that for
them or it'll break you apart depending
on what your sense of purpose is and so
this guy's killing it man yeah this
guy's it's been real it's been a it's a
it's a really good i don't think we've
had that in america for a while it's
been it's a really good example of
wonderful leadership this guy is killing
it and he also uses really cute phrases
like he says something like uh at least
sound bites he's like i don't need he
was he goes america offered me a lift to
get out of here i don't need a lift i
need armor-piercing bullets
oh my god dude you are rambo you are
wonderful he's saying all the great
stuff
and that shit's important and there's a
reason why like have you ever heard
about um where they describe all the
roman emperors as uh orders you know
people who could speak well like now i
understand why
yeah totally there dude i've been uh so
i don't normally read the news or watch
the news at all
uh i like never never turn it on don't
read the newspaper don't go to cnn i
don't do any of it and uh and people
sometimes like i don't know make fun of
me or sort of tell me i'm an idiot for
that
uh just yesterday some guy was like you
know terrible life choice you know you
gotta you gotta be in tune with the
world's realities
and i just think you don't in my head
i'm like if you think the news is the
world's reality like you know you're
watching the world's worst reality show
and um but you know i didn't say
anything to him because you know let him
do his thing obviously you know the news
is is making him a happy cheerful person
so so i i've always had this mindset
which is like don't get pulled like
basically
i find that when people get really into
government and politics the phrase that
my trainer said to me that makes more
sense he's like these people can't
govern themselves but they want to talk
about you know what the government can
do and it's like most people fail to
even govern themselves you can't get
yourself to do what you should do
why are you so worried about what
everybody else should do if you can't
even get yourself to do it and i've
always sort of taken that as like a way
to not get sucked into like 2016 i had
friends who were crying about trump and
all this stuff
and you know i said like i get it it's
not who i would have voted for but um
i just don't worry about that like this
is not i don't worry about the
government i worry about government
myself the exceptions being oh there's a
pandemic i should probably like figure
out what's actually going on what is the
recommended course of action um although
that basically
you know was was not really paid off
because we got a bunch of bad
information um you know at first the
second thing was okay there's a war
going on and this is my first experience
really like
watching a war break out
like there's been wars that have just
been going on forever like india and
pakistan at the border like you know
israel palestine there's skirmishes all
the time and
afghanistan like you know i didn't even
realize we were in it until we pulled
out you know like as ignorant as that
sounds like it just wasn't top of mind
and it didn't
you didn't see it play out day by day
this is the first time i've really seen
it play out day by day so there's
definitely like a
kind of a crazy thing to see i mean just
to see like um
just to see people basically
take a stand was like kind of like
inspirational
then to see like experts coming out like
on the internet like being like hey
civilians this is how you like do
urban warfare from your whip your
bedroom window and like there's this guy
he's a urban warfare expert he's like
you need to drag all your furniture out
into the streets into this s pattern
your goal is to make it so that their
vehicles cannot easily like roam your
streets they need to be making all these
different turns
everything desks lamps toss it all into
the middle of the street secondly you
know drink water because you know you
can't go three days without water so
make sure you're hydrating otherwise you
can't find anybody third here's how you
make a molotov cocktail fourth and he
just had this like checklist i was like
holy [__] is this real life
um and then you see crazy man
you see like you know there's like what
you see in the news versus i'm in these
like telegram channels where people
people are posting videos from like on
the ground
and so you see like
different perspectives
how'd you get in those
uh ben had linked me to two i was i was
sharing some links to them he's like
check this out there's a telegram group
where you can just get it it's all in
ukrainian like i can't unders i don't
read i can't read the text i can only
watch the videos
um or just like the heartbreak like
there's a video that was going viral of
this dad just like because you know they
did a conscription right like everybody
between the ages of 18 and 60 all men
like you're now in the army
and um
there's a dad saying goodbye to his
daughter like knowing he may not it may
not ever see her again and she doesn't
understand she's like a four-year-old
kid and like i have a two-year-old
daughter so that was just like you know
i was just like you know shattered by
that and just that was like you see that
and you're like this is wrong this is so
wrong what's going on like it just hit
in a different way
um and i had heard uh on the all-in
podcast they were talking about this
they go they go yeah like right now the
us sentiment is like no don't don't go
fight other people's wars like don't
send our human lives into that
and then the guy dave freeberger said
he's something he was like you know i
wonder how that will change as the like
sort of media starts to come out as you
start to see videos of like atrocities
and kids and women and
people are going to have a different
reaction when they see that and that's
exactly like literally the first video i
saw that was such a heartbreak i was
like we got to do something i got to
donate some money i gotta saw that same
video i gotta do something here and so
it's just been crazy to see kind of how
it's all
playing out like crazy is really the
only way i could describe it like it's
crazy that this is happening
it's crazy the way it happens it's crazy
that like life gets turned upside down
for people like all the things i care
about on a day-to-day basis
instantly would be out the window
if something like this happened then you
see the financial side like this is
crazy that this war is like i forgot
somebody said this like
banks not tanks it's like we're
basically fighting russia with financial
warfare it's it's crazy it's way worse
like because i was i was telling ben i'm
like putin screw has
he's gonna he's screwed up the only
thing that really matters rule number
one don't [__] with the money yeah
paper putin yeah like because because
money is like the most important money
is more important than lives often or at
least you know that's a perception and
so like yeah it's screwed up and i want
to tell you a point
i want to pump your ego so do you know
who you you said something you didn't
say it as eloquently as i'm about to
explain but nassim
how do you say his name kind of bad at
names to leave okay so he tweeted
something really good so basically he is
the guy who uh anti-fragile i forget
what else he did black swan black swan
yeah and he's kind of an oddball but
he's eccentric his better word and he uh
basically says like don't read the news
that's like what he said has said that
he said that for a long time
and he's like don't read things
he says like don't don't uh don't read
the news only read things if it's like
50 years old that's his whole point and
he tweeted out this yesterday he's like
except my book coming this march buy
pre-order now
yes
and he tweeted this out yesterday and he
goes most days 99.9
of the news is noise
the last few days it's all signal
newspaper reading is useless except in
crisis
and i actually totally agree with that
and that's what you said i read the news
every day but i actually think it's kind
of pointless
until it's like an urgent urgent thing
and that bar the threshold of what's
considered urgent is actually really
high
yeah and also there's a way to like you
can use the news to inform yourself to
gather information to like in my case
it's just like have empathy for what's
going on and just not think about this
intellectually
but the news can also use you and you
have to like figure out where that line
is
are you are are you using the news right
now to gather what you want to gather or
are is the news using you as like
eyeballs that they're going to drain for
the like you bet your ass like you know
fox and cnn every news channel like this
is their
like i'm not saying they don't care
about what's going on but this is their
payday right this is when they get their
spikes this is when they say we have 24
7 news coverage stay here don't move
don't change the channel we are going to
send you drip by drip play-by-play
updates and it's like that's actually
not the healthiest you know like most
productive way that you can live your
life is by like getting hooked onto
their 24 7 you know play-by-play update
of this war so you know that's the kind
of like caveat so this last point i'll
make but basically one of my heroes he's
on my wall here you can't see him it's
ted turner
and ted turner started cnn i think he
started it in like 1981
but it was kind of a failure it lost a
lot of money until 1989 1990 when
america or sorry when iraq uh invaded
kuwait and the reason why is he sent
over a bunch of news stations uh news
reporters and it was one of the first
times that a news reporter could because
of technology could film something and
it be aired live and so it was one of
the first war that was viewed live and
it changed people's sentiment of the war
and it made cnn a huge company that one
year
and that's kind of like what's going to
happen now except instead of a news
instead of like a a publisher it's going
to be facebook and twitter they're just
going to crush for like the next couple
years because we're glued to it and dude
there's uh can i give you the kind of
like the finance or crypto angle of
what's going on here so so basically
the west is doing this like financial
warfare and they're like okay economic
sanctions so we're gonna make it hard to
trade we're gonna make it hard to uh to
buy and sell goods and then they're
doing a form of like um you know they
froze they froze them out of swift or
kicked them off of swift okay so now you
can't now you can't do international
transfers and then they froze the
central bank assets which was like the
craziest move that was the financial
nuke so that was where all of a sudden
you know they had 650 billion dollars of
reserves
and they needed those reserves why
because their local currency is crashing
so i think the ruble lost what was it
like 40 percent in the last day
great so so you know the average citizen
is the one who's paying the price right
putin basically attacked his own
citizens here because the currency is
crashing um nobody wants to hold this
currency anymore there's a bank you know
people are lined up to get money out of
the bank so normally the way the
government props up their currency to
prevent it from spiraling to zero is
they will buy it back using their
reserve assets they hold dollars they
hold euros they hold gold they hold some
crypto and they'll use that to buy back
the ruble but because it got frozen they
can't do that and so that's going to
cause the currency to go downfall so i
think
this time crypto's not going to play as
big of a story but you kind of have to
bet that any country out there who's
watching this is probably going to say
well we probably don't want the u.s to
be able to just freeze all our assets so
why are we holding the dollar as reserve
why are we holding any currency that one
country can uh one country or an
alliance can basically freeze our assets
or cut us off or take us out of the
banking system so i think you're going
to see a pretty big move
first by you know the quote-unquote bad
guys basically first by the folks that
are afraid of the west
to get out of the dollar and get more
get more heavily into crypto because
this is a wake-up call oh wow they can
just cut they would do this they'll cut
us off completely they'll freeze our
accounts and so i think in the next few
years you're gonna see uh different
regimes like switch over to digital
currencies that can't be controlled by
any one country
for a bunch of uneducated dumbasses i
think we did pretty good with this one
yeah we probably just said one thing or
maybe it's ben's russian accent like
that'll be where everyone just decides
you know we're [__] and cancels us
but other than that you know whatever i
think it's good
i thought the ukraine stuff was awesome
did you do you agree ben
yeah i thought it was really interesting
i thought this is the most interesting
news story this is all i want to talk
about so i thought it was interesting
and and
i i think it's cool i think it's cool
that we could actually talk about it
it's funny dude i
so
you know people don't want it either way
so you
i didn't if you don't talk about it it's
like dude how are you not talking about
this what do you you know why are you uh
you think your thing is important
there's a war going on like i tweeted
something else out i was like oh this is
really cool how this is happening some
tech thing and somebody this guy's like
bro kind of insensitive don't you think
it's a war happening
i was like oh am i just supposed to
not speak about anything else
okay and then you talk about the war
it's like oh now you're now you're a war
expert
well you you you wrote something in the
milk road that was great you said um i
think the opening line was uh we're not
gonna mention the bitcoin price today
because it's not really that important
and i know what you guys are thinking
like stay on your lane milk road and the
truth is we know our purpose but we want
to talk about and i forget uh you went
into like the the a bunch of different
stuff but i thought that was a really
good line what did people say about uh
the milk road writing about this uh
let's see i'm gonna i'll open up the
this thing is the like feedback thing is
so uh
helpful but also
you know like daunting at the same time
uh did you see
while you're pulling this up i'll say
something did you see when i tweeted out
uh are there any pro putin people here
what is your opinion i want to hear your
perspective because everyone i know is
is anti-putin and a lot of people got
pissed at me for asking that and i
thought that was crazy yeah i tweeted
something else similar like that i was
like hey so you know just trying to like
you know educate myself like
um
what would be and i think i said it
something like um
i forgot exactly what i said but i was
basically asking like what's the
what would be the most kind of like pro
russian reason for the invasion at first
i was like do do the average people in
russia does the average person in russia
support this right um and then i was
like you know second question is is
basically like what would
uh what would be the like strongest
justification for doing this you know or
you know if you're
if you're like in russia's camp
and um
you know
i didn't get too much flack for it
because i like had to like hedge it like
crazy but it's so crazy you have to like
really um
like soften everything so much
i guess you don't have to but uh if you
don't you know you're definitely gonna
like the discussion becomes about you
rather than just being able to be
intellectually curious and say i'm
trying to understand i'm trying to learn
i'm trying to think for myself and i'm
not saying i disagree with anything i
just want to actually like understand
all the perspectives that you know that
exist so i said deal manning i want to
steal
steel man this shifter
i wrote what would be the most
pro-russian invasion reason basically if
you tried really hard to think about why
this is justified what would you come up
with
and uh and you know then i got a bunch
of answers i got 26 answers to that and
i was like okay that's cool that's
helpful to uh to
and what about the milk road what were
the replies did anyone tell you to f off
uh i'm opening it
what are they what do they say to lebron
james
when lebron james gave his opinion on
some stuff everyone's like dribble just
shut up and dribble lebron yeah what did
shut up and podcast what are they going
to tell me to do shut up and type shot
or i don't know i'm going to read the
first i'm going to read the first three
good like good reviews like we have a
system it's like one one milk cup like
the emoji like one milk is terrible
three milks is average or five milks is
great so
uh the tone the analysis the new war in
size humor this is this has it all
that's five another five one i like the
insight into the conflict going on right
now
another one i think you wrote this
struck absolutely the right tone sam is
that you
or is that a difference um that's not me
i i replied i said this is really good
okay great uh great news later today way
to have a perspective and a sense of
humanity
i'm glad you avoided the business as
usual and dove into how crypto is
involved in this uh and then they
complain about one uh like i made this
analogy because i said this thing which
was like
i love crypto when it's like helping the
underdog right like when it banks the
unbanked or people's currencies
inflating and they can move into this to
preserve their wealth but like there's
an idea that oh russia could use crypto
to get around these sanctions that sucks
and then i was like oh [__] uh how do i
feel it's a moral dilemma in a way
and
i was like then i realized you know like
technology is neutral it's neither good
nor evil
it's just used i was like you know the
example of a car like
you can use a car to you know drop off
your mother at the hospital when she
needs help or you could use a car as a
getaway vehicle to get away from the
you know crime scene it doesn't make a
car good or evil in either case it's
sort of like amoral um
and so some people work and some guys
like disagreeing with that all right let
me see if there's a one star review yeah
was there any negativity i literally wow
this might be the highest rated one
we've had oh here we go here we go
here's one
you should effing stick to crypto and
stay out of politics okay
um number one awful
shut up and dribble no this one not one
one milk awful oh i can't miss the
opportunity to suck on some political
ask
[Laughter]
i don't know what to make of
that and they did the thing where every
other letter is capitalized you know oh
my god oh man reading your own comments
i'm not sure this is even useful i might
just uh leave this up so people have an
outlet but it's like here go yell into
this shoebox
i'm not reading this stuff anymore
i check all of it we have a v8 but right
now we check it all because it's new but
like we have a va who basically will
just summarize the like here was your
score
and here's like the
the like kind of valid criticism and the
valid like
compliments um so i'm just going to read
that from now on and not the like the
raw stuff unless i really need to go
hate my life
yeah there's a bunch of i'm actually for
this maven thing i'm doing i'm talking
about feedback i'm like not all
feedback's important like for example um
if people complain about pricing i'm
like i don't really listen to that i
don't care what they say about price
because i'm not going to change um
another thing is like um if they say
like well i wish you would have sent
that email this is what you see in the
hustle like send that email earlier
sometimes i'm like all right i'll we'll
do it but then once we started sending
at six a.m and i would get complaints
i'd be like i'm not listening to this
anymore
i'm not we're not doing it um and so it
is hard to figure out what is actually
important and what's not and for a lot
of feedback is actually not important
totally it's all noise or it'll whiplash
you you do one thing and then they'll
say one thing you do the other i
remember at twitch this happened we went
to an exec off site and they were like
all right so the feedback amongst the
execs to the ceo and the ceo was like
you didn't listen to our input enough
like we felt out of the loop you guys
just decided it was too top down
and then the next off site was three
months so they spent that whole offsite
gathering like what do you guys think
what are your opinions what would you do
like trying to get like the bottoms up
three months later it was like okay
let's read out the feedback from last
time you know what's happened in the
last three months like god can you guys
just make a decision already you're the
leader you're supposed to just make a
call like why do you keep asking us
you're supposed to have the answers it's
like wow it's like it's like
really extreme whiplash of like you know
you never never have it one way or the
other and the best answer i got was like
if you take 10 pieces of feedback
they're all informative nine will inform
you they'll like they'll tell you about
the person
it's not about you it'll tell you about
them and then one will tell you
something interesting or insightful
about you you have to figure out what's
the one out of ten and what's the nine
that's just about this person like
some guy tweeted some feedback about my
course like saying oh it's going great
like you know it's been awesome blah
blah he was talking about like i love
the energy like sean just it's like a
performance it's not just like here's
some slides and the guy and so some guy
replies he goes oh it's a performance
it's all about energy uh so basically
you you know nothing insightful probably
just a big motivational talk huh stuff
you could have just found on the
internet and then the guy
the original guy responds he's like well
yeah like you know 80 of anything you
can just go google and find but reality
is most people are not going to know
what to google even if they're not going
to go take the time to google so it's
great to like have it all packed in
and the guy's like yeah yeah yeah all i
heard is i paying just i'm paying 950
just to hear sean pump me up it's like
all right so that's
that's about him that's not about it
it's not about the course
the biggest thing when when the hustle
will me first i remember we we hired two
it was just me and uh another guy and we
hired two or three interns and so these
weren't even full-time employees and we
from the beginning we did this thing
where every i think wednesday we would
go out to lunch and i remember uh i
remember the first time we had other
people in that office
i said all right well what do you guys
want to do for lunch and i got three or
four different answers and i was like oh
lesson learned never ask and so from
that point on it was we're going here uh
i and and i said here's what we'll do
every week someone else there's a
decision maker um but you can't ask you
just you decide right and i found that
people are just happier that way and
life's easier and and oftentimes it's
like that with feedback we're just like
i'll listen to sometimes but most of the
time i'm just doing what i want to do
and i'm just going to deal with the
consequences right good night yep can i
ask you a random question about milk
road is who designed the the like milk
jar who did that little graphic
uh i don't know ben got that made uh or
he found that somewhere i think he got
it made from there's a guy who
we featured their um
their dao so it's pretty cool there's a
bunch of designers that got together in
this dao i think it's called vector dao
it's basically like high level designers
and they've basically created like a
like a ad hoc agency
so
companies come to them they pay them and
then like anybody in the dow can like
take the project like form a little
guild like a five people form a team and
they'll go design the thing and
basically it's like an agency that was
like they don't have a hiring and firing
process you just sort of join and you
can either contribute or not contribute
at the end of the day and so uh
the thing is cool but it's pretty
expensive it's pretty pricey so i think
when we were featuring it we talked to
some guy ben met some guy and then one
of the people invected i was like yo i
just like like i like the milk road and
your thing's so ugly like i got it i got
to improve it so are they indian
are they indian i don't think they're
indian no they uh
and then and then
every what ben does is he's like he'll
just post something like hey what do you
i made this design what do you think of
this and the guy's like ben i know what
you're doing you just keep showing me
stuff that's so ugly that like i can't
help myself but go fix it like fine i'll
fix it again and he's done that twice
now
so i just did a reverse google image
search and there's an article written in
the india times and it's using your logo
so
so maybe so maybe that one is maybe that
icon is one that had been found instead
of the design but the guy designed like
all the like banners and the the breaks
in the like
in the in the email itself like the
format of the design of the email
wow and like why do you ask one lady
because i really like the formatting and
and they're the design and it's really
simple like it's basically just that
little milk jar and like that color blue
yeah and i i find it really simple but
attractive and memorable oh thank you
wow that flattered are you describing
sean or the
why am i blushing right
now katie's gotta watch out she's gonna
watch her back
all right that's the episode i think
right
yeah we're 17 sam's like i got a hard
stop at the hour and then i'm like just
we just keep talking about random
useless stuff
[Music]
you